then um Amendment 2023
2420 has now in um formal
language um approved by OS but not yet
voted on by this committee the language
that that we would like to present to
the sub to the full committee and it is
in fact the same language that we agreed
upon at our last meeting is that is that
correct representative T is that how you
remember it okay so that
being the case um then I am going to
close the subcommittee work session on
SV
255 with the intention of when we get to
the full committee
operation um consideration we will be
looking at
2428 okay so this closes the
subcommittee work session and I thank
you we have a few minute break until the
chair will open up the work session for
the full committee thank you
all
all right um it's 10: a.m have we is
everybody are we missing anybody no go
no okay yeah there are people all right
um all right it's 10: a. um and I'm
going to call the meeting of the house J
Judiciary Committee to order and I first
ask you to please join me for the Pledge
of
Allegiance
Al to the flag United States America the
for stands one nation under God
indivisible with liberty and
justice thank
you so um just to to uh kind of give a a
bit of a road map of um what we're going
to do and how we're going to uh proceed
today um we're going to first have a
discussion without uh as part of the
work session of the various bills that
uh retain bills that we have uh before
us um and then
um based upon that discussion when it
when we get to 11 o'clock which is what
the the the notice uh of this session
indicates as a time for the executive
session if there are bills on which it
appears that the committee has achieved
a
consensus um uh I will call for uh votes
on those um on those bills um however I
I anticipate that there will be at least
a couple of bills upon which either we
will not have achieved consensus or that
that there is additional work to be done
um uh and on those bills we will not uh
we will not take a vote today but we'll
uh we'll Reserve those for next
Wednesday um so with that I guess I'd
like to open the discussion with uh with
regard to House Bill
149 this was a
bill um dealing with the right to no law
and it basically
required that there be if if information
was requested of a covered let's say
municipality and could not be provided
um either within the original 5 days or
even within 30 days then this would have
required periodic reporting by the
municipality about the progress of you
know where they were how where where is
the information that's been requested
and why haven't you gotten it and what's
the what's the uh prognosis so to speak
for how long how much longer it'll take
you our
um
uh
discussion of this bill back in the the
last time that we
met um as a full committee this this was
not the subject of uh of uh any
subcommittee but our discussion the last
time we met was that um we we didn't
think that this our inclination was that
this bill should be
ited um and I um agreed that I would
speak one of the one of the reasons that
was offered in support of that which
made a lot of sense was that we have
just we've just created a new uh right
to know on budsman um and that he's sort
of just basically up and running and so
it would make sense if if we were going
to do anything on something like this it
would make sense not to do it right now
I promised uh in that discussion that I
would call the right to no on budsman
and I have to confess to you that I that
sort of over the summer that kind of
completely skipped my mind until I
looked at the notes of what I was
supposed to do a couple of days ago and
then I quickly called him and spoke to
him and said told him what what our
inclination was and asked him if he
thought that there was any particular
need to move forward with 159 now his
response was that he did not so I think
despite my uh my tardiness and being
communicating with him I think is is you
know the information that he gave me was
kind of consistent with what I think the
committee sort of thought in the first
place so my inclination on this would be
again I'm not calling for a vote but my
inclination would be that we that this
bill should be it and if other people
have a different view um discussion yeah
yeah let's have a discussion
on
that is uh House Bill
283 uh which is to uh uh as originally
drafted to limit application fees charge
to prospective residential tenants um
and there was a subcommittee on that I
believe representative Alexander you uh
you were the chair of that subcommittee
so I'll turn it over to
you thank you Mr chair um so our
subcommittee meant met it was uh myself
representative D Lorenzo representative
Horgan and representative Kenny um and
we came to an agreement in the
subcommittee um so that
agreement was amendment that is front of
you amendment number
233h um the one thing that was kind of
up in the air and we were trying to get
guidance from OS was regarding the
penalties components so that sparked um
two more amendments to be drafted
regarding this bill um these two
amendments are
2432h and
2433 um representative Kenny and
representative Reed are on one and
myself on the other um the basic
difference between these two amendments
is
um it's basically
replicated um on representative re and
Kenny's Amendment on line 14 to a
landlord who charges running a
background or credit check shall provide
written results of the check to the app
of such check to the applicant that was
in some language that we agreed to in
the subcommittee and then um the end of
the section lines 19 beyond that is the
uh penalties section which was a
disagreement um notwithstanding
provisions of sub paragraph a a landlord
who violates RSA shall be subject to an
award of the applicant's actual damage
costs and attorney's fees plus $100 my
Amendment does not have that language my
Amendment just basically says that a
landlord who violates RSA this section
shall be subject only to returning the
applicant all monies provided by the
applicant as part of their application
that so that's all used and unused um
money so I I called the courts and I
asked them um how expensive it is to
file one of these petitions it's called
a 540A um they said there's no cost to
the tenant to file this so um it's my
view and there may be some disagreement
that we don't need to add court costs or
um actual damages or anything and just
the simple returning of the fee um to me
is adequate I I think what this bill
sought to do was
address scamming address when landlords
would charge application fees or or
housing providers charge application
fees and those application fees and they
would never rent the unit out they would
just continue to charge those fees um so
you think you know if you go on
Craigslist and you look on Craigslist
and there's a unit for rent and then you
pay the application fee and then you
never hear anything else like this
amendment and the agreement that we had
in the subcommittee which is a great
agreement um would address that and I
think it is really needed and I strongly
believe the final language should
include um the language that's from both
of these amendments um like I said I'm
happy to defer to my other colleagues
but the disagreement came um around the
penalties section so uh with that I'm
just going to leave it up to the
committee to discuss that thank you Mr
chair other um other comments
yes uh thank you Mr chairman um so I
agree with everything that
representative Alexander said until he
uh got to the penalties um I think these
are very modest penalties that act as a
disincentive um you know for bad faith
practices in the future of um actual
damages plus
$100 um to be honest that wasn't ideal
on our side either but I believe that
that is a fair compromise between what
both sides wanted um to make this bill
better um so that and then yes the other
difference was from line 14 to 16 um
which regards that um if a background
check or credit check is ran that the
results um shall be the written results
should be um given to the applicant
which I think is just fair transparency
so I do believe that out of the
Amendments um and the work the
subcommittee did uh 2
432h would be the strongest um and
fairest of the three amendments thank
you yes representative Perez thank you
for taking my comment I don't think the
$100 is enforceable so I don't think it
should be there um so I'm a landlord and
I don't rent it and I'm going to give
him back his money and you say well you
owe me
$100 what are you going to do take me to
court for the
$100 I just think it's not necessary so
that's my
thought yes representative
Andrews you thank you Mr chair my
question is what percent of fees charged
like landlords what percent are
scammers that's a that's a great
question representative Andrew so during
the subcommittee we heard some testimony
um I I'll admit anecdotally that this is
happening on a widespread issue I I
don't believe that this is happening as
widespread as some may testify to
believe but if it were to be happening
the amendment that we came up with in
the subcommittee would handle that um
so I encourage you to support one of
those two amendments I think the big
disagreement is the penalty
section
representative
CH oh yeah this is um perhaps a question
uh maybe to representative Alexander the
I see the difference between the two
sort of competing versions of the
amendment one of them speaks to um uh
damages uh costs and attorney's fees as
well as the $100 so it's more than just
the $100 difference um you referenced
sort of a a inexpensive process I wasn't
sure what that was and like what is the
likelihood of there being uh attorney
fees and other costs and what would
those be so that's a great question so
in the in the court uh a tenant is
allowed to file what is called a 548
petition I just called the court uh
representative gab was in the room um
that petition could be filed it's
considered a priority with the court um
and the Tenant can represent themselves
prosay so it's zero cost to them to file
it so I mean the amendment
2432 with damages costs and attorney's
fees there there wouldn't be any cost
inor attorney's fees because they would
file it as a
540A representative Oregan um yes so I'm
willing to support uh one of these two
uh two amendments as a compromise but in
principle it kind of bothers me charging
um charging application fees to the
applicants although um there there may
be uh certainly a nominal fee is
probably harmless and this is more to
actual costs but we heard a lot about
how the landlords are entitled to the
cost of the time and effort they put
into uh put into making the background
checks which is uh which is true and
obviously no landlords like anybody
anybody else's in business they're not
going to stay in business very long if
their uh revenues don't cover their cost
but I think this particular cost should
be uh should be born by the landlords
and of course they'll pass it on to the
tenants I'm not really really sure it
seems a little unfair to make these
applicants pay pay for it um because you
know they're not gaining any benefit
from the background check especially if
they don't get the uh apartment so it
should be um you know this this like any
other overhead should be mostly paid for
out of the uh out of the rental income
and I know rents are very high and the
costs are very high but that's not the
primary driver of the high rents or even
um or even that's not the primary driver
of the high rents is mostly that there's
like a shortage of supply and an excess
of demand and I guess that probably will
correct itself with some of the new
inventory coming into the market but so
I uh I certainly I'm certainly happy to
compromise on uh one of these one of
these two amendments especially the uh
Kenny Amendment so
thanks
yeah um yeah so it's my understanding
that there is a $126 filing fee for
non-emergencies um so I guess I'll put
it out there as a question is my
understanding incorrect on
that no that's true thank
you representative
Andrew thank you Mr chair so my question
is which I'm trying to get straight in
my mind is this bill trying to penalize
the scammers and if it is why are we
trying are we trying to scam I are we
trying to penalize all
landlords representative Smith did you
have a comment I just wasn't clear on
representative Kenny's
Point what you know as I understood his
point and I I you know I haven't looked
at this recently but I think he's right
is that the the court would if something
is an emergency and usually that arises
in the situation of a tenant that comes
in says you know that the landlord is
trying to evict me like today or or next
week or something like that and I need
to act need to act I need the Court's
relief quickly the court would would
likely not always but likely wave the
filing fee but if it's if it's not that
and I would think that in some at least
in most cases it would seem to me if
you're if what you're talking about is
getting back an application fee well I
suppose if the if the if the tenant was
saying I need this money to to make a
new to pay the net rent at a new place
or make a new application maybe that
would be considered an emergency but
there could be situations when it
wouldn't be um and therefore you would
have to pay the filing fee could um
representative kutab I think you had
suggested that that there might be yet
another option um that would that would
basically if I understood what you were
saying it would take Al representative
Alexander's amendment to uh
2433 and in
paragraph in section two paragraph F
would simp would add to the words shall
be subject only to returning to the
applicant all monies provided by the
applicant as part of their application
plus court costs is that was that
correct yes I haven't filed that yet
though but I that was a suggested
compromise so anybody else have yes
representative gon thank you Mr chair I
like excuse me I like what has been
inserted into Amendment 2432h the
statement of lines 14- 16 the landlord
who charges for a background check Andor
credit check shall provide the written
results of the check to the applicant uh
that may seem like a burden to the
landlord to do that however it also
holds the the landlord accountable that
they are actually running the check as
they are stating that they will excuse
me that they will so I actually like
that part as far as penalty goes and we
could debate this all day long and if
without a without some form of penalty
uh then the law is irrelevant and so
whatever we decide on is a penalty we
want to lock them up in jail for the
rest of their lives whatever you know um
but that's just that was a
joke but um I don't think we need to
wait until scamming becomes more
prevalent before we act and so if
there's anecdotal evidence that
something is taking place it's probably
happening more frequently than we would
like to believe and we you know by
taking some kind of an action now I
think we can prevent more of it from
happening uh those who've been landlords
in New Hampshire for a longer period of
time I don't believe it's a problem it's
the ones who are becoming new landlords
perhap perhaps moving in here from other
places uh where that perhaps was much
more culturally acceptable uh and so I
think we need to protect New Hampshire
uh by taking action now so I like the
idea of taking the statement out of two
two uh 2432 melting it with 2433 and
then if we need to add the statement
like as representative cab suggested
plus court costs as a penalty then that
would be something I think I could
easily vote
for
I'm just trying to clarify so were you
saying that basically to the amendment
that representative Alexander made that
you would just add to the bottom of
paragraph one
that
um that they could get a copy of the
report and
then um add in that and court cost to
the end of the section two it would be
the verbage of all of paragraph one
because they're they're they're exactly
the same except for the one statement M
so take that verbiage and then your
suggestion of plus court costs on uh
plugged in at the end of amendment 2433
what the verbiage in the penalty phase
there plus court costs I think that
would be I think that would work okay
thank
you representative chair thank you Mr
chair um one thing I just wanted to
point out or or ask about the um the
2433 Amendment it says return all monies
provided by the applicant so is it your
intent with that to say that the penalty
if there's a penalty is they don't get
to keep the actual costs that that they
would in the first part of the provision
okay so so there so there is a small
amount of a penalty sort of built into
your language yes so it's the cost of
the credit check background check uh
reasonable
documented fees all that stuff so they'd
be forfeiting that they'd be forfeiting
all the money yes okay and I I I do like
representative Cab's addition because I
think it clears up this discrepancy
depending on whether it's an emergency
or not an
emergency so
I I I think that correct me if I'm wrong
um representative Lyn but isn't it
originally just the judge's discretion
on a lot of this stuff anyways so they
be allowed to return that yeah no they
there that's true it really is pretty
veryy largely discretionary um you know
what the the
I well first before I speak do I anybody
else have any any comments that they
want to make I seeing none so I I guess
I would say
I'm I agree with representative
Alexander and cutab and tur that um
adding the return of the costs to two
2433 is a would be a good idea and I
could support 2433 with that addition I
I don't frankly like 2432 because if
you're um when it talks about damages
costs and attorney's fees that I mean I
I
think to me what we I think we we need
to sort of go back maybe in some sense
to First principles and remember right
now the law is that there are no we
don't regulate application fees at all
and um my inclination is that that one
of the reasons that this whole thing has
become an issue is because of the
housing market and I I I can't help
referring there was a there was an
article I think I don't know if it was
the union leader or the conquered
monitor or whatever but by
representative turot indicating that uh
that you know the the housing the the
situation in the housing market have uh
as it is has has caused a number of
issues and that that situation in the
housing market presumably won't last
forever and things may might change uh
when the housing market changes but I'm
concerned that allowing damages I mean
what you know if a if
a if someone if a tenant or a
prospective tenant claims that um
the landlord didn't uh charge too high
an application fee and I I was out I had
to I had to pay this money um and it and
it wasn't a reasonable fee and as a
result of that I couldn't afford to do
something else and suff suffered some
damage I couldn't afford to buy medicine
for my son or my daughter and I and and
as a result of that he or she was in I
mean is that you know is that some kind
of Damages that could be recover I'm I'm
not suggesting that that it would be but
all I'm saying is it raises if you put
that language in you raise the the the
prospect that somebody including perhaps
um a lawyer a creative lawyer might say
well yes this is this is Damages that
flow from what you did and therefore I'm
you know I'm I'm suing you for three
million doll
um
that fortunately that kind of thing has
happened in the past in other areas and
it concerns me greatly um if we if we
allowed that um that language to stay in
there the the last point I would make is
and this is um with response to
representative grion the the language in
uh
2432 that provides for the landlord to
give a copy of the background check and
credit check to the applicant I guess I
do have some question about the wisdom
of that remembering
that
we're
we're right now we're talking about a
situation where there is no regulation
and this is going to Pro
provide if we pass some version of this
bill we're going to be passing some
restrictions on what a landlord can do
I'm concerned
that as I understand it the way it works
now if a landlord decides to run a
record check or a credit check the
landlord gets that information back and
then makes a judgment on whether or not
based upon what he or she has seen um
the the person is the per they're going
to rent to the person um that judgment
is not maybe right or wrong but it's not
subject to sort of
review um I'm concerned that if you say
that the that this information gets
presented has to be presented to the to
the tenant or perspective tenant now
we're going to get in a situation where
you know the tenant sees the tenant sees
the credit check and it says your credit
score was this and the Tenant says to
the landlord no no no that's all wrong
you can't uh you know don't don't base
it on
this my point is simply
that if you if you create the situation
where that kind of thing is likely to
happen it just puts another sort of risk
factor on prospective landlords and the
result of that risk factor and the
landlord saying to himself am I gonna
now have to you know am I now GNA have
to fight with this perspective tenant
about whether the the criminal
background check is correct or not or
the credit check is correct or not have
an argument with this guy about this um
that's another sort of you know headache
for the landlord and as a result of
that rental prices will increase because
land because uh because it's another
hurdle placed in the in the way of the
landlord my suggestion would be at the
at least in the beginning don't do that
if it turns out that we you know we we
provide we adopt let's say amendment 2
2433 with the change for the recovering
your costs and it turns out that you
know we really
see continuing problems with with uh
application fees then at some point in
the future maybe we maybe we make that
other
change representative gon thank you Mr
chair when a person applies for a a
consumer credit loan now and if they are
denied that loan the the laws require
that the bank informed the the applicant
why they were denied uh it'll tell you
your credit score
and if there's any errors in it it's not
incumbent upon the bank uh that you were
trying to borrow from to correct any
errors it's yours and so the the
landlord is only reviewing information
that was provided to them by some other
authority so if there's something in
your criminal check or your or your
credit check they're not responsible for
the content of it that's only what they
are using so if there's an error in it
you have to fix it as the applicant uh
but providing a statement that says this
is why you were denied
based on what we have in the in this
report that's that's not a matter of of
discussion this the I I denied your
application because of this so we
already do that when it comes to
Consumer loans I don't see why we
couldn't do that for
this yes representative peret I have a
question just too because I don't
understand so I'm applying to rent a
house that you own representative Lynn
and do you tell me what your level of
credit check is required because I do
know they do that in North Carolina they
they do tell them you have to have at
least this much of a credit check so do
we tell them so what's to stop the
landlord from saying well you came in at
550 and I required
560 I I just don't I'm just asking a
question do they R tell people what they
require for a credit
rating I think or subject somebody
correct me if I'm wrong on it but I
think the answer at least right now is
they don't have to I mean they can but
they don't have to this I think under
under any of
the
um under
either yeah under either um
230 2432 or 2433 the landlord would now
have to say I'm gonna you know this is
um uh what would be required for a
satisfactory criminal background or
credit check okay representative
Smith thank you um Mr chair could you
help me know who's on
first I I'm I'm a little bit of a loss I
mean we've been here you know talking
about this for quite a while and I'm I'm
not I don't see the
forward motion that we need on on the
committee at the moment I understand we
have uh several amendments the one that
seems to be um on first base or maybe
second base since now you can start on
second base in certain
circumstances um is
22433 H with additional language that
would come on line 21 that says plus
court
costs and is that the version that
um that the committee seems to favor or
do we need to see
a kind of a show of hands uh so that we
we're not going to bother OSS with doing
an amendment if in fact it's Amendment
that's going to be dead on arrival um
they don't need that nor do we um so I
just kind of want to get a sense of
where the committee is that's a very
very good point I I I think you it's
well taken um so I guess what I would
say is this um could I ask for an
informal show of hands around the table
of how many uh here would support
Amendment
2433 if on line 21 it added at the End
plus court
costs how many would not
favorite let me then turn to let me turn
to uh the next question on how many here
would
support Amendment
2432 and how many how many would not
support
all
right
yes can we ask representative Alexander
why he would not support his Amendment
with adding Court
C thank you for putting me on the spot
um I I think that we should leave it up
to the judge to be able to do that I
think that the judge already has the
discretion to do it I think I actually
think adding those three words is kind
of nitpicking like what I mean we are
going to leave I think strongly leave it
up to the judge I think this is well
formulated there is a penalty they have
to return the entire fee not just part
of the fee so um that's why I wouldn't
support
it okay all right yes can we see who
unofficially who would
support representative Alexander's um
Amendment without the court cost now
that he's explained his reasoning all
right no that's a good Fair yes
sure um so I'm going to put you on the
spot now chairman Lyn thank you for
letting me speak um where it says
subject only to returning I just want to
clarify in your
opinion would the judge have the
discretion to award the court cost if it
doesn't say it in
there well I I I think that's that's an
open question I mean you could say that
this is um that court costs are sort of
different from even without the language
Court you know even if you didn't
include the language plus court
cost it could be argued that even though
the word only appears in subsection
f it what's referred to there is
different than court costs so that court
costs could still be allowed but the
word only is a you know that's that's
that's arguable that's you know and and
some lawyers you know lawyers can make
arguments on that and uh and will so it
you know if you want to ensure that
court costs come back I my advice would
be to add the language Court Cost Plus
court
cost Mr chair could we accomplish the
same goal by removing the word
only I think we probably could I think
we
could I'm I'm fine we fine with that
too so let me ask
this let me ask this question straw vote
suppose on in line subsection F on
Amendment 2433 we remov the word only
but otherwise left that as as it is who
can I ask you to show of hands who would
support
that
who would be opposed to
that all
right yes did you I have a question sure
go ahead please I'm I'm just wondering I
I think the American Judicial System
usually has that both parties pay their
own fees unless it's specifically U
stated otherwise can you think of
another statute where attorney's fee and
or cost court cost are regularly ordered
when it's not specifically authorized by
Statute well I think the problem here is
this is a this this is you know the the
reference
um in in
uh to
subsection
the this whole area 540 is makes
reference generally to the consumer
protection act and specifically where
this talks about a
violation um I I think that might be
diff a different situation um that that
um uh you know that there that somebody
has violated a consumer protection kind
of Statute and despite the fact that it
says notwithstanding sub paragraph a
subar paragraph
a my inclination would be that that that
you know that would be the kind of
situation where a court would be would
be inclined to Grant return of uh of
court
costs but if you're saying you know
absolutely is that true I can't you know
I don't know what a judge would do in
any particular
case
yes the reason that I felt without that
it's not um as easily supportable is
that my understanding from the
discussion is that you could be subject
to
$125 I think fee for filing this this
petition you know at that point it
becomes completely honorous if you're
not assured that if you win you're not
going to get that back it feels as
though you're you're being subject
potentially if it's not an emergency
which I would imagine many of these
wouldn't be you know the the the
potential of not getting your court
feedback could outweigh the benefit of
what you're trying to to
dispute yes representative I I just want
to put this in perspective Ive I think
if there's a situation where a landlord
is clearly violating this
provision the judge I would hope would
award these court costs back um it it
doesn't cost anything other than $126
the tenant should be able to or the
applicant should be able to represent
themselves so I I trust our Judicial
System enough to know that in this
situation if there's something that
egregious where this is happening on a
regular and widespread effort which
again I'm not even convinced that that's
happening that this would be an adequate
way they the judge could award these
fees even with this language the way it
is here's just kind of what
representative Stapleton we haven't
heard from you yet please sorry to
additionally be labor this but
um landlord violates 54
A3 and the applicant takes exception he
gets a lawyer and they file a a
petition uh wouldn't wouldn't a lawyer
reasonably uh put in that petition
request for compensatory recovery of
court costs and maybe other extraneous
expenses uh you know I don't care if
it's taxi cab or because the person
can't drive or or whatever
um I feel that we're stepping on
existing jurist Prudence by adding these
little tidbits here court cost and $100
when an capable attorney could put these
things in his petition am I right or
wrong on
that well I I mean I think you're right
that they could put it in the petition
the question is whether you know in the
absence of of some language allowing for
the recovery whether the court could
award that um and that's that's I mean
that's the question and I
think I think it pro the court probably
would have the discretion to do that but
you know if you um if you want to ensure
that that that it happens that court
costs are returned in this situation
then I to me the safest way to do that
would be to just add the language court
cost so
U oh here's um here's what since we're
not going to be voting on this yet and
we have some other things to discuss to
discuss here's what I would suggest
since it seems like there is not a
particular consensus on any of these um
but maybe we can it it comes closest to
consensus by having a version yet
another amendment of to
2433 which would
add to subsection F the words plus court
costs at the end and so I wonder if I
could ask our uh uh assistant if you
could ask OS to prepare that as another
amendment that would be the only change
to
2433 to 2433 it would add at the end of
subsection F uh as part of the
application plus court
costs Mr chair are you are you asking
that um OLS be asked to do that right
now so that we might in fact be able to
vote on it later this morning yes yes
yes I am
okay all right and hopefully I mean
hopefully we could do it today if it
turns out we can't then
um great thank
you next I guess I would like to
um turn to uh House Bill
362 relative to complaint procedures and
cases before the commission for human
rights and I'm trying to remember who
who was the subcommittee chair on that
uh representative
kab going to
362 so for
362 we had met with the Human Rights
Commission in at the end of June
and we were led to believe that the
oldest case at that time was February of
2022 and we thought okay well maybe
they've caught up things aren't that
bad when we
returned and we started talking about
this in the fall we had some attorneys
who were testifying that they had cases
that had been pending since 2019 so long
story short we ended up clarifying and
the HRC meant that when they said that
2022 piece they meant that that was the
oldest case that was waiting to be
assigned to an
investigator um but that that wasn't the
actual oldest pending in case so at that
point we were kind of like well there's
a much bigger problem
and this particular Bill isn't meant to
fix the problem as a whole there is a
current LBA audit going we're not going
to get the results back for a couple
months this was fixing kind of one small
piece of an overall arching
problem representative Andrew and I felt
like we should really do something to
solve a little bit of the problem even
if we can't solve the whole problem so
we had
voted uh in favor of the initial Bell
however the rest of the committee
members felt like maybe we should
perhaps wait until the audit is
completed and do an overall fix of all
the problems and so they had voted itl
so there wasn't a consensus reached on
this representative
Smith thank you very much um Mr chair
this this is a a bill that um both uh
representative D Lorenzo and I um
initially uh supported in the previous
session no the previous
term um there was significant concern
about what was happening in um the
commission and as a result of this of a
very detailed summer study that was
headed by representative Mark
McLean um we unanimously asked um the uh
the appropriate committee to request
that the LBA conduct not a financial
audit but a performance audit and we
asked that because in example after
example we found
um information that was not not accurate
that was not consistent we found
acknowledgment that the commission was
not in conformance with either the law
or
regulations um that had that the
legislative and the executive
departments had developed um and we
heard from any number of uh individuals
on
both sides of certainly of the
employment issue meaning employers and
employees the delays of years was just
unacceptable the information we went to
the uh and asked that um an audit be
conducted the fiscal committee agreed
that a performance audit should be
conducted and immediately the um they
they began to collect their information
they have been working on that for any
number of months they have ex we do not
know the specifics because they are
absolutely uh as they should be
completely discreet about not sharing
with us anything until they finish but
we can observe certain things in that
they have had to do um investigations on
their own without getting information
that they could get from the commission
again and again again we saw problems
meanwhile because we were concerned we
uh enthusiastically supported getting
additional
staff for the human uh relations
commission we thought that that was
certainly one thing that should happen
and the finance committee agreed and in
fact in the budget additional staff was
um agreed to and that
staff would be available as of the start
of the fiscal year which was July
1 it was not until last
week that the first of those positions
was
advertised and I you know in in Open
Session the commissioner had explained
why she had not moved before but if
Staffing was so
important tell me why you wait from July
1 to November 1 to even advertise when
you know once you advertise it's going
to be another number of months before
you could
hire um I initially felt very strongly
that we should pass the the bill that's
before us we've learned from lawyers on
both sides that there are in fact very
few cases that would be
affected um and we did ask um if the two
sides of in terms of the lawyers would
see if they could come up with a
suggestion of how this could work best
and they couldn't and they didn't I um
would suggest to you that this is a
commission that is is in real
trouble and I don't see the
value of because I know how committed I
am to making that commission one of the
strongest commissions we have in this
state I don't see the value of fixing
what I I guess would cruely refer to as
a hang nail when um the heart and the
lungs might be might need help first so
I don't think we accomplish a thing by
making this one change and I think it is
responsible for us to wait until we get
the results of the report that we
requested on how on on the performance
audit of that commission before we make
any changes to make one little change
now and then realized that we've
accomplished nothing in the whole order
of things I think is just not good
governance other other
comments representative Horgan um well
yes I first of all I guess I'll say that
I generally support the performance
audit and those performance audits are
very thorough and the results are
usually very interesting and probably
it's probably painful to go through the
process but I've seen a number of those
I'm I mean I think the commission uh
needs a lot of improvement I'm not quite
as negative about us speciic
specifically I think there's an emic
problem throughout state government with
like a large number of entities which uh
deal with similar issues and they're
probably I think maybe they're all less
than perfect well of course they all
they're all less than perfect but then I
guess maybe this is this is what's in
front of us so we may as well start by
looking at that one so I certainly
support the uh waiting till after the
performance audit I think maybe we're
being a little bit too harsh on them and
they're probably um I also say like the
original
bill was just to uh change make a tech
fairly technical change with most
procedures Z just only the complainant
can move to another venue in this either
the complaintant or the respondent and
can and uh so some individuals in legal
profession were concerned about that and
it's uh theoretically it's probably a
good change although I managed to dig up
the bill file from
1999 which actually one of the
co-sponsors of the bill that were
that bill was passed in 99 was a
representative for Sandy uh Sandy ke who
was until a few years ago member of this
committee so that was they added the
respondes basically I think it's a
compromise to get get you know the uh
Bill through the house in Senate and
signed by the governor so uh
I I definitely think we should probably
leave the law away at it for now and
certainly we'll uh we'll await the uh
performance audit with interest and I'm
sure there'll be many many useful
suggest questions in it but other
comments so I guess I um the only
comment I that I would make is is this
I I could be persuaded at some point if
the Human Rights Commission properly
functioning um that the change that has
been proposed in the original amendment
to allow only the the claimant but not
the I mean only the the plaintiff but
not the employer or or uh the other or
other respondent to remove I might be
able to support that um if the
commission were were operating
efficiently and and sort of properly for
lack of a better term but given I I tend
to share the the concerns that have been
expressed by representative Smith um
about what is happening there and in
that circumstance it seems to me that
both sides of a dispute should have an
escape Val which is what um the current
law allows even though it's a sort of in
particularly from the the perspective of
the respondent uh in those cases it's a
pretty inefficient Escape valve at least
it's some Escape valve and given given
the the circumstances of what's going of
of the current situation at least
as I think is is an accurate one um I I
don't think we should eliminate that
escape valou at least now and so I I'm
in agreement with representative Smith
that the
appropriate uh resolution of this bill
would be itl uh to await the uh
performance audit I wonder if I could
just ask could I just again informally
could I just ask for a show of hands how
many would support itl for this
bill and who would oppose
okay all right um all right um next I
want to go on for discussion purposes
and I I I since I'm virtually
certain that we will not be voting on
this bill today because I think that
there will be we will this is the one
bill that I think we likely will be
completely at loggerheads on is House
Bill
396 my I guess what I would what I would
say is this
my impression and then I will open it up
to discussion if people have a different
take on this but my impression on 396 is
that as as you may know there is a there
is an amendment that was proposed by
representative Perez back in the spring
um that was voted on and uh and it
failed be on a 10 to 10 vote um my
impression is that nothing really
changed on that and that if that motion
were if we if we discuss that again now
that that would that all again would
fail on a 10 to 10 vote my suspicion is
that there would then be a motion um of
uh of itl and that that would fail on a
10 to1 vote and then we would be back to
the original Bill we'd have a vote on
that and that would result in a 10 to 10
vote and we would go to the floor in
January with a no recommendation so
that and what I would suggest so I guess
what I'm really asking is does anybody
have kind of a different take on what is
likely to happen um number one and
number two if that is what's likely to
happen I we will not vote on that until
next week representative Smith well I
guess there two things um um one would
hope that uh someone might change his or
her vote of course I would hope they
would change it to my side but who knows
um but uh if that's not the case there
is another choice and that is that we
could um keep the bill and uh uh work on
it over the summer and then be able to
make a recommendation to the next
legislature of how we might want to
handle it and um uh and why would we do
that we would do that
because in all cander it will help to
keep the temperature down I'm not too
cold I'm awfully cold right now but I
mean just out to a nice moderate
temperature where we who are facing some
very serious questions that affect so
many of us in so many ways might want to
put this this one issue aside while we
try to try to really come work hard to
come to agreement on other issues um I'm
not suggesting that there will suddenly
be a bolt of lightning and we will see
the light and have a clearer idea of
where to go I just guess I like to cons
consider the possibility of putting off
have having to have um what will be a
very
painful uh discussion on an issue that
affects a certain number of people in
very different
ways anybody um yes representative Perez
thank
you as I told you a couple of weeks ago
I will not be here next week I'll be at
the um National Education
symposium
I would like to see us deal with this
today since it is my amendment that I am
putting forward um I would like to see
it dealt with today so but you're you're
in charge so well I was not yeah no well
you know what I guess what I would say
is this I I I as as I think I mentioned
on when we had our caucus I I
representative Smith had indicated to me
quite a while ago that she was going to
have someone absent from this uh from
today and um and as a result of that I
basically said to her look we'll if we
are in if we are in consensus on bills
we'll vote on them today if we're not we
will put that off until uh until next
week um and so I'm first I'm perfectly
happy to have a discussion about 39 I
mean if you want to have a discussion
and talk in favor of your motion um uh
I'm certainly willing to have a
discussion on it but I think it I would
not be prepared to vote on it today I
will say to you that I mean you have
nothing you have you have no worry at
all that your motion your Amendment will
be introduced next week it will be it
will be introduced by nobody else by me
because my your amendment is basically a
mirror almost of mine um M Mr chair yeah
um I was not aware of Representative
paris's um conflict and I believe that
we each owe
loyalty um to the members of our um of
our committee um and I I'm we do have
one person missing we have arranged uh
to have a substitute for today so in
purpose in in in terms of the the
vote the vote itself would be a vote of
20 people 19 of us plus a substitute and
I personally feel that I owe it to my
colleague on the committee since she
feels so strongly about this and it is
her amendment that in fact we do vote on
it um today all right no that's F I
appreciate your willing to do that uh uh
it's never easy I mean it's you know
another Solomon question here but um
since in fact we don't have to divide
the baby it's okay all right well I
appreciate that very much represent
Smith All right so um
so I guess back to my my my suspicion I
mean it's certainly I and I say this is
certainly my view my suspicion is that
to the extent representative Smith was
talking about a third option being
interim study basically for this bill um
I would oppose that and my suspicion is
that the members of my caucus would also
oppose that and so that vote I think
would come to a 10 to 10 vote also but
if somebody thinks you know if somebody
had does think that they have a
different view on that and we you know
then that we're only we're only
discussing right now we have no idea how
right no no no but I'm just sort of
asking if if if somebody thinks that my
recitation of what is likely to happen
is inaccurate um please you know speak
up representative
sableton I don't have another
interpretation but we spent a lot of
time on on this and I think we should
move the
question I okay well as I say I I very
much appreciate representative Smith's
willingness to all that
yes right well we can yeah we can we can
begin the executive session
um all right but um so I guess what I'd
like to do then is I think we can go
through several bills relatively quickly
before we actually get to making uh
uh what
um
oh so we'll take a we'll take a
two-minute recess thank
you
all right I'm going to call the uh the
meeting back to
order all right so this we're now in the
executive session of the Judiciary
Committee um and I'm going to take up uh
I'm going to kind of go in order of of
the bills as we have them on the uh uh
schedule that representative uh clerk
has prepared um first I'm going to take
up HB 149 and I will recognize
representative uh Alexander for a motion
I'm I'm happy to defer to representative
Smith if she
prefer this is 149 149
okay me okay well I I'll move um in
expedient to
legislate all right representative Perez
there a second for that I would like to
second that all right all right so uh
the motion has been made and second
ended uh on House Bill 149 uh with a
recommendation of uh
itl um any further discussion regarding
that bill I think representative lenu
outlined the discussion around it pretty
well and I'm ready to vote all right all
right um then I'm anyone else have
anything to say all right then I'm going
to ask the clerk to please call the
rle vce Sher Wallace yes rep Alexander
yes rep Andrews yes rep testerman
rep
Stapleton oh he wasn't here okay um re
was he in the room when the motion was
made it's okay okay rep trip no oh yes
sorry rep gon yes clerk votes yes rep
Perez
yes rep Smith yes rep Horgan yes rep D
Lorenzo yes rep Kenny yes rep Paige yes
rep McBeth yes yes rep Divine yes rep
lonza yes rep Eaton yes repur
yes chairman Lynn yes motion passes 19
to0 all right and
um any reason that this can't go on the
consent
calendar right it will be on consent and
um representative Alexander can I ask
you to prepare the report unless
representa Smith wants to I will do
it all right write it for
you that sounds great we are one you
know with regard to this can I ask
please the the bills that we vote on
today could I ask please that you get
your reports to me by the close of
business tomorrow I realize that the
we're what we're going to be voting some
of the bigger ones we will not be voting
on today I think most of the ones we'll
be voting on today will be relatively
with one exception uh relatively easy
but I'd like to get those reports in for
both for for my purposes so I have time
to review them and secondly I think it's
important that the clerk's office not
get bombarded on you know next next
Thursday with 10 million reports so
please get them into me by tomorrow
night um next I'd like to take up um uh
House Bill
283 um and I recognize uh
representative um okay Mr chair um I
move um HB 283 ought to pass and I move
Amendment 24
2023-24
33h yes is there a
second second I'll second that second by
representative
trip we're Mr chair were you planning on
waiting for another amendment well I'm
wondering do we do we have that have we
heard anything from
OSS so let's get this all right so
that's all right then we'll we'll pass
on uh 283 I'll I'll take back my motion
until all right till we we get some
response all right um let's turn to uh
then House Bill
362 uh and I rep recognize
representative
Smith thank you um Mr chair um I move um
itl on
360 two and would like to speak to my
motion once there's a second is there a
second second by representative
mcth
yes um
Mr chairman this is um an issue which
the Judiciary Committee
has thank you this is an issue which the
Judiciary Committee has struggled over
for a very long time longer than this
term it is a struggle that is well worth
taking because the work of the human
relations Commission
is so important to the Integrity of
state
government that um it deserves all the
attention that we can possibly give it
because of
concerns previous Judiciary Committee
asked the um and got approval
for um the LBA to conduct a detailed
performance audit
I hope by now that all members of this
committee are familiar with the work of
the LBA in performance Audits and if
there is someone who isn't I'm hoping
that they will go online and just pick
one at random to see how thorough those
reports are how they start with the law
and they go to the rules and they
address issues with in great depth they
identify problems but they don't stop
there they identify Solutions as ways
that whatever agency is being evaluated
could best meet their obligations to the
Constitution the laws and the rules of
the state and in
addition they put time limits on and
kind of a
checklist um so that in no and all of
this is done with consultation with the
staff of the
agency um there are all over the country
there are states that look at our LBA
process with admiration and I would lead
the cheering Squad because we
have a a performance audit now underway
that we will not see un to the spring I
believe that it is responsible for us to
take no action on the specific question
that's before us relating to how the
human relations commission operates and
instead suggest that we vote itl on this
bill and be prepared when the um when
the uh performance audit is finished to
look at it in Great depth with all the
people we need to help advise us to come
up with the best possible plan for the
future of that
agency anyone else wish to be heard on
uh with respect to House Bill
362 all right are we ready for a vote
all right I would ask the uh clerk to
please call the
role Vice chair Wallace yes rep
Alexander yes rep Andrews yes rep
testerman rep Stapleton yes rep trip yes
rep gon yes clerk votes no rep Perez yes
rep rep Smith yes rep Horgan yes rep
dorenzo yes rep Kenny yes rep page yes
rep McBeth yes rep Divine yes rep lonza
yes rep Eaton yes repur yes chairman
Lynn yes motion passes 19
to1 consent any problem with consent all
right um that's up to what's up to the
yeah I'm right yeah no she she doesn't
object
to and will be a Minority Report all
right and that represent Smith could I
ask you to prepare the
report thank
you
all right
um I'm going to skip 396 for a minute
for a moment and turn to
um uh HB
533 uh
FN um and I'm going to uh recognize
myself and I am going to make a motion
uh to I to itl uh that bill uh is there
a second I second I'd like to speak to
that for a minute um you may recall that
this bill originally was um the original
bill was designed to it would have
given the Department of Education the
authority to Pro prosecute and I don't I
use that in a uh not in the sense of
prosecute of like crimes but to
prosecute civil cases before the Human
Rights Commission that involved uh
allegations that arose out of department
of education related kinds of things
like a claim that a teacher had
discriminated against a student in some
way or whatever the Department of
Education wanted the authority to
prosecute those cases before the Human
Rights
Commission uh itself as opposed to
having the Attorney General's office Do
It um eventually
we expressed a lot of concern in this
committee about that um and eventually
the the Department of Education
indicated that they uh that they didn't
they weren't really pressing us to go
forward with that um and that they were
going to work try to work out some kind
of a memorandum of understanding with
the Attorney General's
office it's not clear to me whether they
have actually done that or not but they
haven't come back and you know asked us
to re to revisit the original bill at
any rate there was an amendment to the
bill that that really had dealt with a a
different subject and that was the
Department of Education having subpoena
power uh for certain uh matters um there
was there was some controversy about
that also
um as a result I have introduced with um
great input from representative kutab
and and perhaps others
um a new bill this year that deals with
that deals with subpoena power for the
Department of Education it's very um
it's very limited and specific as to
what kinds of cases the department would
have subpoena power um and I'm hoping
that that in the next legislative
session we may be able to achieve some
consensus on that but um at any rate
that's a long way of saying that's the
reason that I don't think there's any
need to to proceed with any version of
53 3 right now um so and that's the
reason for my itl motion anyone else
wish to speak to
533 well yes I agree that this bill is
unnecessary it was also well poorly
there are few emissions in the drafting
one it didn't specifically mentioned
Charter Public Schools which although
those are probably covered under school
um it doesn't cover other education
providers who paid for public funds
whether through the uh so-called
education Freedom account programs are
just through other programs so those are
also not covered there so it's like uh
even if even if the basic idea was
something I would support it would need
I would have expected to be like
significantly drafted because there's
like a lot of uh they left a lot of
stuff out of the original bill but um
I'm certainly happy to I certainly agree
that it's itl and it's certainly s
certainly happily vote Yes on the itl
so anyone else wish to be heard on uh 5
33 representative Perez thank you V I
feel very strongly about the app of
right of subpoena power for the
Department of Education and only because
of the new bill being proposed will I
vote to itl
this anyone else wish to be heard all
right then I ask the uh clerk to please
call the role a motion uh before us is
itl of House Bill
533 Vice chairman Wallace yes rep
Alexander yes re Andrews yes re
testerman rep Stapleton yes rep trip yes
rep gon yes clerk votes yes rep Perez
yes rep Smith rep Horgan yes rep D
Lorenzo yes rep Kenny yes rep Paige yes
rep McBeth yes rep Divine yes rep Lano
yes rep Eaton yes rep tur yes chairman
Lynn yes motion passes 20
to0
consent anybody have any problem with
that all right consent and I will write
the uh
report um next
um uh R House Bill 641 relative to
clearance inspections following
identification of a lead exposure uh
chair recognizes representative
Alexander thank you Mr chair I move in
expedient to
legisl in expedient to
legis motion been made and seconded um
I'll second that okay all right right
second by representative SMI the answer
love that um all right um representative
Alexander you wish to speak to your
motion yeah we originally held on to
this bill thinking there might be more
information or make this more of a
widespread issue but it seems to me like
there was only one or two lead
inspectors that felt grieved by the
current process and not many more so um
with that I think we can safely itl this
bill anyone else wish to be heard on uh
House Bill
641 right ask the uh clerk to call the
role please Vice chairman Wallace yes
rep Alexander yes rep Andrew yes re
testerman re Steepleton yes rep trip yes
rep gson yes clerk votes yes rep pz yes
rep Smith rep Corgan yes rep D Lorenzo
yes rep Kenny yes rep page yes rep
McBeth yes rep Divine yes rep lonza yes
rep Eaton yes repure yes chairman Lynn
yes motion passes 20
to0 again
consent um next um I would like to uh
turn to uh House Bill 6 U
52 um and I'm going to make a motion uh
to itl uh house bills
652 is there a second I'll second that
and I'd like to speak to uh the motion
if I
could this um bill
I I think we I I know I have and I know
others have given considerable thought
to this bill and I've gone I frankly
have have gone back and forth wavered uh
uh
uh as as as I've thought about this over
the course of many months now
um and there has been there have
been at at our subcommittee
session
um
a suggestion was made that
the the proponents of the bill sort of
agreed that they didn't mean by the bill
to say that any
time somebody was
something bad for lack of a better ter
something adverse was going to be said
by a public
body um in a meeting that was closed to
the public because of that for that
reason because somebody was there was
going to be some adverse mention made or
discussion made of somebody um they the
proponents of the bill agreed that just
because that was going to happen didn't
mean that in every that that the person
should have the right to be notified of
the of that fact and to be present and
to to be able to be heard in their own
um in their own defense they suggested
that um what what they're really getting
at is only if some action was going to
be taken against somebody um at at such
a session should the person have a right
to be present and and to be uh to be
notified and to be present and to speak
in their own behalf so I drafted a
proposed amendment which I didn't dra I
didn't file officially but I circulated
among the subcommittee and to others um
and now I've this morning um or actually
I should say uh yeah this morning two
other proposed amendments were given to
me by um
uh
representative uh Brom O'Brien and the
more recent an amendment was given to me
by uh representative Perez and
representative um
Alexander um that expands
on
um the idea of somebody having the right
to be present um if if uh
some
action is going to be
taken
uh see Pro provide to any Vote or to if
some action is going to be taken against
that individual
um and my concern about this my my basic
concern about and and by the way the ex
the the amendment by representative
Alexander and Perez contains a number of
exceptions um when the bill would not
apply my concern about this is twofold
the the first concern is
that
the all of these proposed amendments to
to the right to no law don't really have
anything or at least very little to do
with the purpose of the right to no law
which is what is public and what is not
public this this these proposed
amendments for lack of a better term
they support to give
somebody due process rights in other
words the right to be the right to be
heard uh the right to notice and to be
heard and to have an opportunity to to
sort of speak in your own defense be
before something bad happens to you as a
general proposition I don't have any
problem with that idea of course that I
mean that that makes
sense but it doesn't make sense in the
right to no law
and it doesn't make
sense to do it at this time I mean the
pro for example let me just read to
you one of the the last section of this
of the amendment that has been proposed
it says the requirements of of sub
paragraph one that's the one that would
now give you the right to to to be
present to have uh council president to
speak on your own behalf subsection two
says the right the requirements of
paragraph one shall not apply to the
office of professional lure and
certification or the boards and
commissions under the office of
supervision including but not limited to
responsibilities of the offices boards
commissions pursuant to RSA and then
list it lists a whole bunch of one two
three four five six 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14
it list 14 statutory things where to
which it wouldn't reply apply my con
concern is that if we were to pass this
am this is flying by the seat of your
pants um we don't know and I don't I
please please understand I'm not
suggesting for a moment that anybody's
acting in bad faith but we haven't had a
chance to really look at these study
these in any de in any depth and more
importantly if the implications of this
bill it seems to me this if we were to
pass this this bill would
say on a very broad
basis that
anybody who uh who a some public board
is going to be speaking adversely about
and may take some action about may take
some adverse action to has a right to
have has a right to to be notified and
have an opportunity to speak
and it's not we don't know what kind of
action we're talking about how
significant it is um anything like that
and to put that in the right to no law
just seems to me to be a really bad idea
if if if something like this is is going
to be proposed in other words if we want
to create as a matter of Statute a
general right of due process
um for anybody that may face certain ad
some adverse action by a public body
then then that may be a very good idea
but let's do it in a careful thoughtful
way and not in the right to no law
because it doesn't really it really has
very little to do with the right to no
law it should and the implications but
of this potentially could be very very
broad um
so that's my basic concern about moving
forward with this bill at this time I
just think it's not it's not ready for
Prime
Time representative
Perez thank you respectfully I
disagree um you're a lawyer I'm a nurse
retired both retired we look at things
that a little different you're looking
at it as due process okay which makes it
very more legal e I'm looking at it as
we when we first discussed this we had
the
municipalities represented in all this
I'm looking at this as a right to know
because this is for the little guy this
is for the person who lives in a
town who somebody doesn't like them on
the Town Council or this or that or the
school board who says blah blah blah
blah blah okay and it goes back to the
town's councel or the school board and
they
decide to get a lawyer and to start
Prosecuting this person when that that
person has not had an opportunity to
even know what this is
about
a something that I can't talk about
just happened to show that this needs to
be done and not go to court because
these type of there's a name for it when
frivolous what do they call those when
frivolous suit no no there's a name it's
shotgun or something like that this type
of thing is happening more and more and
more and to make it part of legal ease
and not part of the 91a which which
protects the I feel that the protect 91a
protects the little
person I this is where it needs to be
and this is
happening day in and day out I know it's
happened to me I know it's happened to
other people who sit on this committee
it's time that John Doe had an
opportunity to find out who's knifing
them in the back before they have to
you're a lawyer thank you yes
representative Alexander thank you Mr
chair I also am like you and I wavered
on this bill for months and something
happened to me recently in town that
makes me believe that this bill is
needed more than ever um when a certain
board
discusses a a communication I sent to a
director of of town and they're just
they're talking talking about me in a
very derogatory way and the only reason
I would know about it is to file a right
to know request which I did and it came
up to where they were saying some very
hateful things about me over
email I think that this needs like we
need to expand the right to no law to
deal with these sort of situations when
not even me like I'm a State Rep I can
handle it like if you slander me like I
can't sue you like I'm an elected
official I can handle this but I really
do feel for the little guy who does not
know their rights does not know that
they're allowed to be that they're
allowed to file requests like this I
believe strongly that this this
amendment that we propose needs to pass
um I mean based on a personal situation
but also um this happening to a little
guy all over the
place
other anyone else wish to speak yes
representative disbled
sometimes employees are and other people
in business or government do things that
are UNT toward or even wrong um or
malicious
and
sometimes officials have to come
together to uh discuss that even before
taking any
action and to protect the reputation of
the person in question I believe it
should be done in PR priv
it at least for that those that board to
consider and exchange the information
and to make some kind of a
determination um before they go
forward now if if they're going to take
an action of dismissal or punishment of
some
sort does not when that punishment is
delivered the person has a a right
to uh ask for a he
hearing and to bring forward that uh
information so that they have an
opportunity to contest it we talking
about two different procedures here
information gathering in in the
non-public session and then a possible
uh hearing e either private or public
requested by the person who is
affected
um this is why I'm having a problem with
excluding that information gathering
that discussion among responsible
supervisors and people in position to
consider whether whether there's been a
fault committed um and if so how
egregious it might be or or not before
um bringing someone into that
process yeah sure thank you this is
saying I'm going to give you an example
this is saying okay here's the Town
Council somebody over there in town
complained about me that had something
to do with the
town the town Council gets together and
discusses it nobody's saying they cannot
discuss it without me but before they
take any action before they decide to
you know take legal legal action or to
you know censor me or
whatever I have a right to go before
them find out what it is that the
complaint was and to then hear my side
of the story I'm going to tell you that
there was just something brought down by
a judge who
said it was a a town did a very
frivolous frivolous thing and this is to
stop that now we're not talking as if I
stole from the town or I threaten
somebody's life we're not talking things
that should not even be to the Town
Council they should have gone directly
to the police department we're
talking things that can be as what
happened to representative Alexander
slanderous there's a lot of that going
on now a lot of it and because people
are speaking up and if you don't like
what I have to say well then I'm going
to complain about you this protects the
little guy and yes he may have a right
to a hearing but not everybody's going
to do that get a
lawyer let me find out what your
complaint is before you crucify
me anybody else have anything to say
representative
State I I was just trying to draw a
distinction between information
gathering and exchange discussion versus
taking an Express
action when you go to express action now
you've got to follow some protocols and
some law and some rules um and and I I
think that this bill doesn't address the
difference between information
discussion and The Taking of
action any other com yeah I think I mean
to me I think you really hit the nail on
the head Mr stat and representative uh
Perez this you know you said this
doesn't apply to the situation of
somebody of somebody that stole money
for example but the problem is that
under this language yes it would yes it
would apply to that because if the the
and that's the problem it's too broad
you if if under under this proposed
amendment if if somebody came in to uh
one of one of the Selectmen for example
came in at a selectman's meeting and
wanted to say that you know we have we
have information that someone someone uh
has been who who we do we contract with
or whatever we do we do some business
with or something like that has been
stealing money or ripping us
off that be and that was going to be
discussed in a non-public session um and
may with maybe the result being that the
that the the board of selectman says you
know we better we better notify the
police about this under this language
they wouldn't be able to do that without
notifying the person by the way we think
you're stealing money which might be a
you know that there could be I can
imagine many many circumstances in which
the last thing you would want to do is
tell the person that who who you think
is involved in in some kind of ongoing
theft by the way we know about it um and
the and we're referring it to the police
you might you might there may be any
really good reasons why you'd want to
keep that information confidential uh
and the police when they get the when
they get it they may very well want to
keep it confidential until they get to a
point where they think it's appropriate
to to uh to sort of you know come out in
the open um with their investigation
that's the problem there certainly I
agree with you there are situations in
which in which before some final adverse
action is taken against somebody they
ought to have the right to be noticed
and a hearing and all that but the way
this is worded it it's not limited to
that it's much too broad and that's my
problem with it any any other
discussion all right I guess we're ready
uh for vote the motion uh before us on
641 is itl and I ask the clerk to please
6 652 I'm sorry 652 sorry 652 is uh itl
I'd ask the clerk to please call the
role face chair Wallace yes yes rep
Alexander no rep Andrews yes rep
testerman re Stapleton yes re trip yes
re gon
no clerk votes yes rep Perez no rep
Smith yes rep Horgan yes rep D Lorenzo
yes rep Kenny yes rep paage yes
rep McBeth yes rep Divine yes rep Lanza
yes rep Eaton yes rep turer yes chairman
Lynn
yes motion passes 16
to4 okay I'll write the report uh this
will not be on
consent is there will there be a
Minority
Report good do you want to take a crack
at it and then I will look at it that
sounds great I'll take a crack at it
he'll look at it all
right report
motion
what yeah you know what actually
representative Wallace or represent
Smith KY will the will the minority be
or
otpa minority is has the right to decide
whether they want it to be OTP or otpa
and if it's otpa they have to specify
which amendment which amendment okay so
so you and you'll you'll do that in
your Minority Report representative
Perez it's it's otpa with amendment
number 243 eight each okay all
right okay all
right yeah all right um
so next I'm going to turn to House Bill
255 um and I'm going to recognize
representative
Smith thank you um and the motion I'm
going to make is your mic's off your mic
your mic is off oh I can put microphone
off I never think people want to hear
what I have to
say okay I am uh
moving oot
TPA on sen on um
senville
two 55 is that what I'm doing that's it
255 with
Amendment
h a
second
okay has it been seconded yes okay so I
wouldn't want to speak otherwise
um this is um a double
header we have two
bills before the committee today dealing
um basically with
privacy um each of the bills applies to
to private sector
businesses neither of the
bills uh applies to
governments SB
255 provides information privacy
protections for New Hampshire
customers of most but not all larger
companies selling goods and or services
and doing business in this
state it allows them to opt out of the
company's use of their personal
information for marketing purposes and
by allowing them to look at obtain a
copy correct and delete personal
information held by the companies that
is the crucial part of SB
255 there are a number of other uh uh
specifics which is why we have labored
so long and hard at these
bills
um the amendment that we're proposal
proposing provides privacy protections
to more individuals by expanding the
number of companies covered by the act
and we do that by reducing the threshold
of coverage from a company having
100,000 unique customers in this state
to
35,000 we reduce the threshold of the
group referred to as data Brokers from
25,000 to
10,000 we require procedural uniformity
to make it easier for consumers to
exercise their rights under the
bill rather than allowing each company
to establish a own procedure so we have
these procedures are in notifying
individuals of their rights in opting
out of Marketing programs and in
requesting access to changes in or
deletion of their personal
data um we ask the Secretary of
State to um set the standards and
establish
procedures understanding that every
every one of these entities must file in
any event with the secretary of state so
it is not we're not treading new
territory or causing the Secretary of
State To Tread new
territory
um we provide uh means for
um
uh the the Attorney
General to notify a company of a
violation we allow time for the company
to cure that violation with no no
problem at all and then if it's repeated
the attorney general has additional um
uh uh has additional obligations to
act part of what we do in in this bill
is also reflected in the other Bill the
house bill uh 3
14 um and in any case we require that
the companies comply with what is the
most protective of the
individual um the bills are written
separately they one one begins in the
house one begins in the Senate um they
address different parts but of the same
problem yet they can stand alone and
they are written to stand alone I will
say that if in the fullness of time both
pass then there would be some ease in
making it possible to have cross
references between the bills um but
we're careful not to do that now because
we're not presuming um that we know the
action so that is um I think as briefly
as I can present them they are it's
incredibly important the one thing I did
not say and I should say at the
beginning and at the end is that this
should not be before the New Hampshire
house or Senate it should not be before
any other state house or Senate these
are issues which should be addressed
nationally we should not expect
corporations to be able to comply with
what is required in one state as it
differs from another state we should
have a National Standard but in the
absence of the US Congress being willing
to act in something that we think is
incredibly important and Incredibly
timely we've chosen to take this
approach and we have tried in large
measure to um act in a way that is if
not exact that is sympathetic to what is
going on in other states all recognizing
that the last thing we want to do is put
an undue burden on the private sector
thank you Mr
chair anyone else um wish to speak with
regard to this bill so I yes
representative Stapleton thank you Mr
chair
um mine was more of a question here I'm
looking at page three of line one of the
amendment of the amendment okay uh
relative to personal data collected
processed sold or disclosed in relation
to price route or
Service Such terms are used in the
airline deregulation
act uh or by an air carrier subject to
the ACT um unless it's someplace else
why only excluding Airline traffic and
not Railroad
passenger um trip or or bus line
um are we missing something by not being
more inclusive in that particular
exception what what
line page three lines one two three and
four oh um exception P right I see that
um um exception P I believe that the
reason for these and you'll see you know
for example in the next you'll see
control Substances Act um uh is to try
to make sure again that we are not
setting up
competition with existing federal law um
and wanting to make sure that as as much
as poss as has been brought to our
attention trying to keep track of those
um circumstances in which these issues
are addressed in other
contexts does that answer your question
well no not really I mean we've had a a
railroad
deregulation in the 8S um as well as
they make reference to Airline
deregulation I just wondered why one
mode uh can be Exempted for purposes of
price route or service analysis and not
um water rail or bus
line which are in the same
Transportation sort of a business and
that might and that information may be
useful for uh determining business
purposes and roots and so forth I I hear
you and I agree with your um with your
premise but I do believe that the reason
is says either the non lawyer I see the
lawyer on my left is aching to answer um
and so I'm smart enough to yield to the
lawyer I think that the answer is this
and I and I should say as you may know
um a large part of the meat of this bill
um was was contributed to by by uh a
whole bunch of of representatives of of
I don't mean representatives in the
sense of of members of the House of but
uh of people that have intimate
knowledge of of uh of how this bill how
these bills have been dra have been
drafted in other states and intimate
knowledge of what federal laws might
conflict and so I think the short answer
I'm almost positive on this but if
there's somebody in the audience who who
thinks I'm wrong on this please speak up
I think the answer is that it's what
what these various exclusions are
designed to cover is to prevent this law
from conflicting with federal law and I
think that the answer to your question
is that it's only the airline
deregulation act not you know the not
some Railroad Act or some steamship act
or something like that like for example
the Jones act it's not it's not those
laws that contain some language about
privacy I I believe that that's the
reason why these specific laws are
referred to um but uh somebody thinks
I'm if that's not right um speak up I'm
I'm but I'm F in other words already
covered by existing Statute in the
federal well no no no in other words I
think I think just to use the railroads
as an
example because the railroad laws you
know the national Railway act and other
th those laws are pretty old they didn't
my suspicion is that they don't have any
language in them that deals with privacy
issues whereas the airline deregulation
act a much a much more recent one um I
think that would that developed in the
Carter administ around the time of the
Carter Administration that probably does
have some of those things and so that's
why they're they're referring to it only
that one as opposed to um railroads yeah
they the Stagger the staggers act that
deregulated uh railroads I think it was
late 80s um as you say preceded maybe
this focus on privacy whereas the
airline that's that's fairly recent then
the airline
deregulation um I'm not sure but I'm I
no I'm not sure either but I again as I
say I I I think if there was some land
if there was some provision of a
railroad regulatory statute that
that dealt with privacy issues um we
would we would it it would be in there I
got you thank
you other anyone else wish to speak to
the so the oh I'm sorry representative
Andrew thank you Mr chair I have a
question back in March when we were
discussing these bills a gentleman from
the AG's office and I think I have the
name right a Brandon Gerard came in and
spoke and the AG's office was against
this bill I take it because they don't
have enough help and etc etc so what has
changed that they can handle any of this
if if this is
passed well I I think a couple of my
recollection was that they that the the
AG wasn't against the bill the AG was
against was uh was suggesting that there
should be a private right of action as
opposed to just the Attorney General's
office enforcing it and was saying that
the um the consumer protection didn't
division didn't have enough staff they
were sort of already overworked and that
this would be you know giving them
putting too much of a burden on them but
my understanding is in the budget um we
have provided additional funding for the
consumer protection division
specifically uh and and representative
Smith if if you have something to add
please do well I think that's part of it
I think it's been addressed in a number
of different ways one was the way we've
tried to handle um the issue of a
private right to action of action um
versus going to the attorney general um
part of it is the
standardization of
um which would be established actually
by the Secretary of State but to make it
easier for the attorney general and
um we've
changed some numbers in terms of um who
would be covered by this and who
wouldn't be covered by this um
and all the subsequent meetings that
we've had on this um I am not aware that
although the Attorney General was
noticed of of all the meetings I'm not
aware that they um felt any need to come
to
um uh address any continuing concerns so
I'm hoping that they're going to be much
more comfortable with this
now well I guess I should just say that
the it should be just so there no
confusion 255 the this bill as
amended does not call for a private
right of action there is no private
right of action under the bill it has we
have changed some of the language
concerning the circumstances under which
the Attorney General can act um and
whether he has to allow a cure or rather
has discretion to allow a cure and that
depends on the timing of when when the
Attorney General uh acts um but there
there is still no private right of
action under this bill as amended and
again that was know we had a number of
people with a number of different points
of view working on the subcommittee we
got a number of a lot of different input
and these are all comp you know there
are some people I think if if you would
ask them what what what would they
prefer they would have said I prefer
that this provision be different or I
prefer that this provision be different
or I prefer that there be a private
right of action some people had had diff
had a different View and so this was you
know sort of a compromise that that the
subcomittee came to and I I agree
completely with representative Smith I
think it this is is a good bill in the
fashion that it's in now and I hope uh
people will support it I I would Sugg
that I think everybody is a little
unhappy I think uniformally everyone is
a little unhappy and so I consider that
a
success I agree any any other
uh if the issue of private right of
action was brought up during hearings
was there a reason why it was not put
the provision was not put
in well I think I think yes I just said
we had I mean there was there was there
were suggestions for there being a
private right of action and um the
subcommittee you know concluded as we we
made a number of compromises along the
way one of them was that there not there
shouldn't be a private right of
action right anyone else uh should be
heard all right so the motion uh before
us by representative Smith is otpa on
255 with uh
Amendment
2420 do we have to sorry we have to we
have to vote on the adoption of the
amendment and then the OT first the
amendment so on the motion of adopting
Amendment
2023-24 20 Vice chair Wallace yes could
we just do a show up hands or do we need
a you want
let's let's do it just for yeah just um
rep Alexander yes rep Andrews yes rep
testerman re Stapleton yes re trip yes
re gson yes clerk votes yes re
Perez yes re Smith yes rep poran yes rep
D Lorenzo yes rep Kenny yes rep Paige
yes rep mcbath yes rep Divine yes rep
lonza yes rep Eaton yes rep tur yes
chairman Lynn yes motion passes 20
to0 you want me to do the next yeah all
right so we're ready then for a vote on
the on the underlying bill so for otpa
otpa and anybody anyone wish to be heard
all right then I ask the clerk to call
the role on the underlying bill otpa
vice shair Wallace yes rep Alexander yes
rep Andrews no re testerman yes re
Steepleton yes rep trip yes rep gon yes
clerk votes yes rep Perez no rep Smith
uh yes rep
Horgan no rep D Lorenzo yes rep Kenny
yes rep Peach yes rep McBeth yes rep
Divine yes rep lonza yes rep Eaton yes
rep Tura yes chairman Lynn yes motion
passes 17 to
three all right
um representative Smith would you like
to write the report or you want me to I
would be happy to write this report all
right all right be and will there be a
Minority
Report no minority okay no
minority we still have to go on the
regular calendar regular calendar right
yes no
minority all right um then um we do
314 Mr chair I just for the committee I
want you to know the amendment to 283 is
ready as well oh all right okay I it oh
you have it okay all right so let's go
back to should we go back to
283 all
right
okay okay you know what the way
represent representative Alexander the
the new Amendment came out with your
name on it I know that you yeah so I yes
I anticipate that's because I was the
chair of the subcommittee I'm gonna just
say that but I probably will not be
voting for that Amendment all right but
will you introd I mean will you
introduce the amendment I think somebody
else should make the motion okay all
right all right so that's that no that's
fine so let's go back to 283
then oh yes do you Scott do you have you
have copies oh I do yeah yeah yeah let
me let me so can you pass those that way
if you would pass those that
way okay thank
you
all right so does everybody have a copy
of
uh so we're back we're back to uh House
Bill
283 um and uh representative cutab do
you want to make a motion or do you want
me I sure um I move to adopt amendment
number
2023-24
41h I'm gonna move to adopt the
amendment and then I'll move to otpa
after Mr chair yes can I ask a question
certainly sure
um representative Alexander um when I
look at
pH so in reading the amendment um the
new paragraph Pro prohibited practices
and sec in security deposits rental
application fees
um and it goes on to say prior
collecting any fee as part of a rental
application or renewal process um I have
questions about the renewal process
being part of this is there a reason for
that uh that was just what we discussed
in sub committee that was the language
that was put in there so
um I mean we talked about it in
subcommittee
so that that wasn't so if I could Mr
chair that wasn't the change that we
made that was in all of the versions of
the Amendments yes um the only change
between the two amendments 2433 and 2441
is three words at the end of online 21
that says plus court costs okay so my
concern is that
the way that I read this amendment it
actually
adds fees to the renewal process or
makes the fees possible for the renewal
process do you agree with
that I believe that language was in the
underlying bill as well I know yeah but
I mean I think since since since
application fees are not regulated now I
think the I think the answer to your
question would be landlord's if if we do
nothing land land I don't know whether
landlords charge application fees for
Renewal but they could because I think
it's not regulated right now
right so um Mr chair with it in writing
here does that make it
regulated it would make it regulated to
the extent of this of what this law says
yes okay thank
you um all right
um
so yes well you know before we can I
just add did I a second oh so wait minut
so so I will second uh representative
kab's motion on uh 2023 2441 and now um
representative kutop would you like to
speak to your
motion so this is the SE amendment that
we had talked about before in the work
session this is just indicating that the
court costs could also be awarded back
to the tenant or prospective tenant from
the
landlord uh
representative McBeth did you have a
question so yes your honor I mean yes uh
chair so I um I had overlooked that this
the uh renewal process as well whether
it was in the underlying bill or not I
don't I'm trying to look now at the
statute I think that is adding to the
statute and I think the housing
statute's you know it's a it's much more
black and white process so um I I don't
know I'd like to I think that is adding
a whole new process allowing for this
app the fees um but I just would like to
clarify that does then does anybody
know um representative Alexander do you
have any idea anywhere else is there uh
the authorization of these application I
mean the renewal fees is that anywhere
else in the statute I'm I'm trying to
look I don't see it I am not a lawyer I
just have a masters in public policy I
don't know I haven't read all of
landlord tenant law so um I can't tell
you that
answer you know can I just
representative MC Beth could I just ask
you a question I I mean I don't have the
statute in front of me but I was under
the impression somebody correct me if
I'm wrong my impression was that the
current landlord tenant statutes that
are on the books did not deal with
application fees at
all I'm unclear that's I just wanted to
be clear I don't know I'm I I I thought
there I mean I thought that was the I
wish we had representative re here but I
thought that the whole purpose of this
bill whatever version we were talking
about the whole purpose was to begin
some regulation of application fees that
didn't exist before and
so you know I I if that is correct and
representative Kenny do you have
some well um and Mr chair the reason I
waited until this last you know
amendment was that um I wanted to see
the changes before all of
this before this amendment
so now it looks like it's standing and
to me it opens a door for renewal fee
renewal fees thank you you yeah you see
I guess the thing that I don't when you
say opens the door if if applications
are not regulated the door is open now
there would be nothing that so I'm not
quite clear what this would subject
renewal fees to this law whereas it's
not if right now there is no law so
presumably I mean I don't I don't know
whether landlords routinely charge
application fees for Renewal but if they
do there's nothing that prevents them
from doing it now as I understand
representative I certainly can see where
renewal
applications might be needed for a
landlord for example your situation
changed you lost your job you lost your
job I'm your landlord I know you lost
your job I
you know want to have some renewal
application based on the fact that you
change jobs or lost your job this gives
the tenant the right to get those fees
back if they're denied after the change
in situation whereas if you don't have
that there and I'm questioning renewing
your application because of change of
jobs I don't have any way to get back to
it if you don't accept me as your
staying
on Mr chair yeah
um the renewal is a lease renewal
fee I think representative Perez thought
it was a a renew to renew their housing
application
okay no I meant if you're renewing your
lease definitely but your situation has
changed I as a landlord might want to at
that point get some new information on
you thank
you so it I mean the way it reads I
think it would be prior to collecting
any
fee which could be a part of an app
rental application process or collecting
any fee as part of a renewal process so
that
um I I guess I'm I'm I'm still not sure
that I understand the concern because
it's not I mean unless unless there
somebody can point to an a provision of
existing law that
somehow limits or regulates application
fees um or renewal fees and I don't
think there is but if somebody can point
that then that might change this but if
there
isn't this this does regulate it where
right now it's not
regulated yeah the reason uh because I
wholeheartedly agree with you Mr
chairman I just I don't see that
language to be problematic I think we
spent a long time over the summer
working on this bill then we spent 50
minutes today to come to a compromise
that that a majority of the committee
could be comfortable with so I do think
we're kind of exhausting the
conversation at this point um and would
just really urge uh my colleagues to
support this amendment because it is a
good compromise that we all worked on
together thank you I and I I would Echo
your sentiment on that I I I tend to
think this is you know I know
representative Alexander's committee put
in a lot of work and they had various
suggestions they came to an agreement
whereas I my recollection was we were
pretty divided uh last last spring on
this
I think this is a good compromise Mr
chair I guess I
misheard um representative Alexander is
the chair of the
subcommittee did I mishear him when he
said that he his name is on this
amendment but he doesn't support
it oh I think you heard him correctly
that's correct represent Smith thank you
for that that he the plus court cost
part is the part that he I think he has
a problem any any viol in in my opinion
again I'm not a lawyer but any violation
of 5
540A would allow a tenant to file a
petition with no court costs um that's
just the way I interpret it I think no
court costs is it's just it's just not
needed so I I don't like to tie the
hands of the
Judiciary Mr chair could I ask you a pro
what your plans are
for how long are we going to go here or
are we going take a break um uh and come
back or are we going to take a break and
come back next Wednesday and the reason
I ask is before we vote on either the um
Amendment or the bill I would like to
ask um if I could meet with my
Democratic colleagues for about five
minutes sure you know what would it make
would it make sense to take a lunch
break that is you're in charge and I
follow your lead lead
um uh my my inclination would be this is
a good time for lunch let's let's take a
recess for uh and be back at uh one
o'clock one o'clock one o'clock all
right
great sorry
Mar
um
you know we have some additional
sh I'm fine with that I'm absolutely
fine with that but this
is
e
no no V yes that's it we've cleared
everything out don't
worry
however way not my
state I said it's
unacceptable myat every
time I
told
look
yeah where you
going anywhere good are you going to you
taking the train Kaitlin can I have the
uh tally sheet for
toand
it's
I think there's two tally sheets I don't
know if they were the same
vot
all right I'm just waiting for
representative Smith to
return
have we heard how many bills we're
getting you there still nothing no I
haven't
heard so we won't start those until
January
January so you
same
okay
and
so um all right so I'm going to call the
uh uh committee back to order uh and we
have um we have before us um Amendment
uh 2023
2441 to uh House Bill
283 I believe it's been moved and
seconded um so does um anybody does
anybody else want to speak to the
amendment all right so I think we're
ready pardon we can do a
hande okay sure all right anybody have
any any objection to a hand vote okay
all right then we'll do a we'll do a
roll call have a roll call vote on uh
two on Amendment
um and I'll ask the clerk to call the
role
please Vice chair Wallace yes rep
Alexander no rep Andrews no rep
testerman rep Stapleton yes rep trip no
rep
gon yes clerk votes yes rep Perez no rep
Smith yes rep Horgan yes rep D Lorenzo
yes rep Kenny yes rep Pig yes rep MCB
Beth yes rep Divine yes rep Lanza yes
rep Eaton yes rep turer yes chairman
Lynn
yes motion passes 15 to
five all right now we're on to the main
uh motion I mean the main bill um anyone
any further discussion anyone want to
speak on the main
Bill all right then I guess we're ready
for a roll call on the main bill Vice
chairman Wallace yes rep
Alexander rep Andrews no rep testerman
no rep Stapleton yes rep trip yes rep
gon yes clerk votes yes rep Perez no rep
Smith yes rep Horgan yes rep D Lorenzo
yes rep Kenny yes rep page yes rep
McBeth yes rep Divine yes rep lonza yes
rep Eaton yes repur yes chairman Lynn
yes motion passes 16
to4 all right um so that will not be on
consent um representative could I ask
you to write the report sure all right
and is there going to be a Minority
Report yes okay all right um minority
Alexander Alexander Alexander
yes all right so what I'd like to do uh
next then is turn um relatively quickly
to House Bill 314 because we are not
going to be able to take a vote on that
bill today because there's some language
that would need to be added um that um
that OS will not be able to uh draft
um
uh today so I what I what I'd like to do
initially um is to is to make
sure is is to tell you what the changes
are to propos changes are to this bill
from the official Amendment um
that was
uh that is
amendment 2414 is that correct yes
that's 2414 okay so
um the
changes hang on one second yeah so the
changes are um and
this the the first change that you're
going to see in the official Amendment
from
um um
the draft that has been circulated among
the subcommittee is that entirely
appropriately OS put the definition
section in alphabetical order in other
words the way I had drafted it you know
personal information was was was the
first term that was
identified um and it went on whereas OS
appropriately listed the definition the
the the terms to be defined in
alphabetical order so for example
available to the public comes first
government entity second personal
information third and thirdparty
provider comes last um that uh that's a
change that is made in
the uh uh in the official draft which I
would propose that that remain the same
because that's just the you know the
practice that is used by uh by the
legislature in defining terms um the
next thing that you will
see is that
um the
um
insection
507 H2 I'm sorry I should back up you
will see that in the the draft that I
have circulated I have referred to this
bill as
507-i whereas the official draft refers
to it as 507 DH and you may you may be
asking yourself oh wait a minute we just
passed 255 that's also labeled as 507 DH
how can you have two different chapters
that have the same number and the reason
is again aols
appropriately the next available chapter
in 507 is H and since the legisl OS
doesn't know that 507 that 255 is going
to pass if it doesn't this this would be
H if it if 50 if 255 does pass then this
will they can just change this to I so
just so you so you know that um the
other
changes second does everyone realize
that
no you have the official but I've been
i' yes but the chair is not working on
the official right now
right no
what what
I'm I'm sorry this we're going we're
going to teach the chair that he should
put his name and the date always
that's it it it looks it doesn't look
like an official one because it's not
looks like this right it begins by
saying amend HP 314 by replacing all to
the enacting cluse with the following
right yeah no I'm you're you're
absolutely right I should have done that
and I didn't uh and I apologize for
that don't need but I'm let me but as I
let me let me go through then and say
the
only
um the
only substantive
changes from the official Amendment are
the one I just referred to you about
putting the putting the uh the
definitions in alphabetical order
renaming ruming the chapter from 507 I
to 507 H for the reasons I just said um
there is another
change that
um let me make sure that I've got this
right yeah so another change
that I I propose
making
to 314 is in 507
H2
um and that is by adding
right by adding in the second sentence
of H2 the one that
begins um an individ the one that begins
uh third-party providers of information
and
services I would begin I would add to
that in the as a as a introductory
paragraph unless specifically authorized
by by
law third party providers of information
shall not uh and that's
because um
the a number of people have informed us
that there are there may be various
statutes that
specifically um authorize or in some
cases even direct um uh third- party
providers to provide to disclose
information in certain circumstances and
we didn't want to run a foul of
that the other
change that um is a substantive change
is you'll notice in the official version
it has three exceptions in to to when uh
excuse me could you cite the page and
the not line
number sure on so on on page on from the
official draft on page
one it would be line
29 the sentence that begins thirdparty
providers there would be added to the
beginning of that sentence the words
unless specifically authorized by law
and then the rest of the sentence would
go on to read the way it does the next
change that would be made
there is
that you'll see that then that on the on
page two of the official draft there are
three
exceptions a such individuals have given
explicit consent B emergency situations
and three the information is disclosed
in accordance with RSA 507
H3
now one of the things that some some of
the people that are interested in this
bill have um
said is um that if that that
um there may be that it's customary now
let me put it that way it's customary
now
for various entities that would be
covered by three4 by this bill that is
utilities for example banks credit card
companies it's customary now for those
institutions on their own initiative if
they have information that there's that
there's you know some fraud or some
crime being committed or that somebody
is being harassed or that there's some
some other kind of illegal activity they
will now on their own disclose
information to to sort of you know
attempt to uh bring that to light or
counter uh somebody being hurt by that
they may disclose that information to
the customer in question did you know
that you know your credit card was just
being used by um uh this person or that
person or they might disclose it to law
enforcement
so I would propose adding as a
fourth uh exception under in other words
it would be a uh a b c and d and I would
actually in insert what I'm about to
tell you as C and May and make uh
make the the the one that now reads the
information is disclosed in accordance
with RSA 507 H3 I would make that
subsection D and
for um C I would add the language that
says
um
uh to prevent to prevent detect protect
against or respond to fraud identity
theft
harassment uh or malicious deceptive or
illegal
activity um so I would add
that and then the last um the last CH
substantive change is in
H3 Roman numeral
two and
three
um the changes that I would make there I
and I believe that the reason they
weren't included is that these were
changes that I that we came up with or I
came up with and our subcommittee came
up with after this was submitted to OS
for drafting it
says it
establishes certain limitations on what
information can be the timing of the
disclosure of certain information so for
example if it says that when
information when a government entity
seeks the disclosure of personal
information either pursuant to um a
request or a uh demand based on a
subpoena the The Entity the the covered
provider that gets that
information can't provide the
information to whoever's whatever the
governmental entity that is that's
requesting it they can't provide it for
days and within five days of getting the
request they're required to disclose the
fact that they've gotten the
request to the person whose information
it pertains to so in other words if the
bank issues a subpoena to me I mean if
the uh if if the government issues a
subpoena to my bank for my bank records
um the bank can't comply for 10 days and
within five days the bank has to notify
me saying but you know by the way Bob uh
you know the county attorney's office
issued suboo or the
the Securities Department issued a
subpoena for your records and the idea
of that is that I will then have five
days if I think that there's a basis to
quash The subpoena for me to to go to
court to move to kashan the exception to
that would be if the government
governmental entity and this happens
with some frequency if the governmental
entity
says um to the to the uh to my bank in
my example don't tell Lynn that we've
that we've issued this subpoena and here
is our Authority for us to De to demand
that you not do that or if they have a
court order that says don't do that and
and again uh that that is something that
happens with some frequency but unless
the the governmental entity had that
made that request the bank would be
required to
disclose within that 5day
period subsection
three which
is which is new this is not included in
the official draft but Roman numeral
this would be 507 H3 Roman numeral
3 this again is a notice requirement but
it deals with what notice
the um has to be given by the The Entity
that receives a government request in
the case of if it's either a if the if
the demand for information is either uh
occurs in an emergency
situation or it
occurs uh pursuant to a search War
because unlike a unlike a subp in an
emergency self it's sort of self- evant
but
with the in the case of a search warrant
unlike a subpoena a search warrant
doesn't say
to the person that the warrant is served
on it doesn't say please provide this
information you know either like right
away or tomorrow or whatever it says in
effect we're taking this information
from it's a seizure it say it basically
says that the government is seizing this
information so there's no there's no
opportunity in those situations for an
advanced notice but what paragraph 3
would say is in those circumstances you
have to give at least contemporaneous
notice in other words the bank has if
the bank gets a search warrant for my
records they have to
contemporaneously provide notice to me
that they' that they've you know been
served with a search warrant again with
the caveat that if the if there's a
court order or the or the whoever's
obtained the search War has legal
authority to demand that no disclosure
be made then that's okay but there has
unless there's that Authority the uh the
information has to be
provided
um so that's those those are the
substantive differences from from the
version that I uh that I drafted and the
official Amendment and so I guess what
I'd like to do is have a discuss
basically say does anybody I think these
are designed to provide more privacy
protection to to
uh you know than than the the official
Amendment version and so um I throw it
out for if people have questions or
concerns or think we shouldn't do
this I I just have a question about
process how does a contemporaneously
notice if if you've got a search warrant
is that before you allow them to come in
or right as you're allowing them to I
think it's I think it's basically as
yeah no I think it would be yeah I think
it would be because as I say a search
basically a search right would be sort
of right soon as the first opportunity
when you know either while or after the
warrant is being
served um and I think that makes I think
that makes sense now this you know this
makes it a little harder on frankly on
on some prosecutors it may make it a
little harder for them uh uh you know
they may have to they may have to jump
through some hoops that they wouldn't
they wouldn't jump through and other uh
under other without this bill but I
don't think
it's as as somebody who spent a lot lot
of time as a prosecutor I don't think
it's an undue it's an undue burden and I
think it does provide additional
protection for for privacy interest so I
what I would propose then is unless be
unless somebody has an objection I would
ask I will ask ol between now and next
week to make the changes I've just
discussed and we can then vote on
obviously I don't expect you to vote
without seeing the actual language I
will have have that um uh next week do
that make sense to
everybody good all right thanks I think
we're I think we're done
um oh no we're going no no no we're
going to 396 next we're going to 396
next um all right so
now um I would like to turn to uh HB
396 and um I would
recognize uh representative Perez I
understand you have an amendment do you
have that in front of you if you don't I
have it here okay all right great so I
it's Amendment uh 2023
441 representative Perez this is the
amendment that I put before you way back
so that's why it has on it 2023 so it
has not been changed
since then um I feel that this before
before you speak to it we need a second
I'll I will second your motion oh okay
second okay I move to ought to pass
Amendment
04418 a second okay are we ready yes you
may I speak to so it hasn't been changed
since it was presented last year and um
but in spite of the fact that it hasn't
been
changed um I've done a lot of research
and um a lot of talking and um to people
and there's been a lot of issues that
have been brought to me and brought out
in the public that support this but
originally having been a intensive care
and an ER nurse one of the first things
that came to my mind about biological
sex is basically
you there are different lab values
different all kinds of different things
for a biological male and a biological
female that are taken into consideration
in an emergency room because your lab
values are different all kinds of things
are
different but I'm going to tell you the
same thing that I said to you back then
why I feel this is very important um one
of the things I've had multiple parents
come to to me uh urinary tract
infections for young girls who won't use
bathrooms there was just a big article
um that was sent out about a young girl
who had her facial fractures and her
teeth all knocked out in a field hockey
game um we've seen all kinds of
incidents where um female um
incarcerated have become pregnant there
are
circumstances that
would it would be in the best interest
of the
individual to be using their biological
born sex with I don't think that it I
have nothing against any
lgbtq any gender identity I have nothing
against any of that but I do feel that
when we're talking according to the
um according to the intersect Society of
America we're talking about a minority
of people who have rights and their
rights need to be respected and not be
discriminated
against but we have to consider the fact
that we live
in a
government where the Maj majority of the
people need to be taken into
consideration as well and you cannot
provide equity for 100% of the people at
100% of the time but we need to
provide equity for we need to provide
safety dignity respect and
privacy for the minority I mean for the
majority especially in sensitive situ
situations safety is a huge issue if I
am a
female going into a female bathroom
because I am a female and identify as a
female I can't change the bathroom that
I go into but if I am identified as a
female I can change the bathroom that I
go into perhaps a private bathroom in
the schools perhaps the nurses that's
not taking that's not discriminating
against them that's providing equal
safety for everyone
involved I just feel very strongly that
there are
circumstances um where people need to be
protected and you know I
always I wonder
why why people are against this if
anything um one of the big issues
women are being discriminated against in
sports women are being discriminated
against the girls basketball team is
being discriminated against doesn't
anybody see that's a form of
discriminating against them this is to
protect discrimination it's not to
hurt any one particular group it's to
provide safety
dignity respect for all groups
anyone else wish to be heard on uh
Amendment
441 representative hardan did you wish
to be
heard I'll
pass all right um all right so see
nobody else I I guess I
would what I would say is I think I've
said this before and I'll I'll try to
keep it very brief I think that this
that this is an appropriate amendment I
think for I I I agree with
representative Perez and I think it's
important to point out that a couple
things first of all this is not a
command to anybody this doesn't direct
this doesn't say that prisons for
example must do this must classify on
the basis of biological sex it doesn't
say that um schools must classify on the
basis of biological sex with with regard
to restrooms it doesn't say that they
must classify on the basis of biological
sex with respect to sporting
competitions in which uh biological sex
is kind of recognized to make a a
difference to Performance it just gives
them the opportunity to do that without
having it claimed that they've violated
the Civil the the Civil Rights Act and I
would point out as I I think I've said
before that it's really important to
remember that unlike for example racial
classifications with regard to sexual
classifications it it is a reality that
some level of separate but equal is
really allowed if if that wasn't the
case you wouldn't have Title Nine would
be
unconstitutional because it it provides
you don't that you have you have equal
opportunity for women for example in
sports but it doesn't say that women get
to play on the boys's football team or
that there can't be two football teams
or I'm sorry two basketball teams or two
baseball teams or whatever there can be
and that in itself is not a violation of
uh of of federal law of uh the
Constitution so I think that these are
three very narrow circumstances in which
it does make sense to classify on the
basis of biological sex
I think um most of the public would
agree that it makes sense in these
limited situations to do that um and so
I I uh strongly support this
amendment other yes representative
Smith thank you Mr chairman um your
comments about separate but equal I
found very interesting in terms of uh
trying to differentiate
um uh you know the difference
differences in terms of of sex or gender
whichever we're talking about at the
moment from race um religion other
things and I thought that's you you gave
me something to think about but when you
move to Title Nine um that's where I
lose you because the reason for Title
Nine wasn't for separate but equal it
was because the practice that was
consistent across the country was that
we use public funds or not but what I
care about are public funds for example
in schools in other bodies um to provide
athletic opportunities for men but not
for women so the purpose of Title 9
wasn't to say that there had to be
separate opportunities for women it was
to say there had to be opportunities for
women um and that is I think
differentiates from
your um the separate but equal General
and from why we have Title Nine I
disagree with you um
and I don't think either one one of us
will be able to prove the correctness of
our position when you say that most
people would agree with you I think the
answer is possibly that most
people really don't care at all they're
not thinking about it at all and they
don't necessarily think they have to
think about it all um about how someone
who chooses to identify
in one way should be allowed to live
that person's life I think G
particularly in the Hampshire
historically you know we were a we are a
Libertarian state where we try to say
that the government should stay out of
private lives out of the business of of
of private lives so I think that us
deciding that in one or in your case I
think three cases it would be okay but
not in others is beside the point I
think we should
just not pursue this matter I don't know
about the rest of you and it is true I
come from Durham and I acknowledge that
I have
never received a
call from anyone in my district or when
I represented Madbury same thing um and
I don't know of any one of my colleagues
other than
representative Perez who has received
many calls from people who are offended
by this so I think we have enough things
to worry about where no one else is can
step in accept government in this case I
think we can leave people to live their
own
lives uh representative hon um yes um I
think uh you mentioned uh you mentioned
Sports in particular so uh Sports all
the sports competitions in New Hampshire
are you know they're some independent
body that regulates them even the
intercol actic sports there in Hampshire
interaccial Sports Association which is
a private organization although most of
his members are are uh Public Schools
you mentioned girls on the football team
um girls have been playing on not many
girls but a few on um football teams for
for many years I think we' even had a
gentleman came in who I forget what if
he did play division 3 college football
he even he mentioned that and he was
actually in favor of this bill but he
did say that he one of the teams he
played against when he was in high
school did have a girl on the team and
he seemed to think we he seemed to
complain that she was not a good player
which uh she was probably the best
player they had because that's the coach
put him in so I think U that
particularly sporting competitions that
should be the competitions out a case by
case they should decide and I think all
of them Pally in a women's sport you
have to at least you know your gender
identity has to be sincerely female so
there's language in that so that's uh as
for the thing of Massachusetts I don't
know much about it except people making
fun of it on Twitter but that's uh that
probably that's an unfortunate thing
that probably could have happened even
if a uh you know a uh CIS female player
hit hit that player hard enough in the
mouth or if a male player had hitting a
male player hard enough in the mouse
that's I mean they have mouth guards
protect against that but they weren't
100% effectiv I don't know if the gender
of the person is
uh you know the I don't know whether the
so-called biological sex the other
player had much to do with it I mean
certainly we are going to here in the
floor debate I'm sure that um we're
going to be treated the information that
uh men are often larger than physically
larger than women but some women are
physically larger than other women too
so that's uh some men are physically
smaller than most women so I don't think
that's
uh so I think the the sports part of it
I don't think we should be legislating
we should let them regulate regulate
themselves and um and also know I think
you alluded to situation with Vermont
high school basketball the basketball
team in question the player everybody
was so upset about was actually not a
not a very good player in fact when I I
tracked down the videos on YouTube and I
wasn't even sure which one it was was
surprised couldn't tell which one they
were complaining about in term the one
they complaining about was well once
again that's probably the best player
the coach had that's why they took her
off that's why they sent her on the
court but she was not a dominant player
at all she wasn't really um you know
she's good enough to be on the team and
good enough to play but she was not
blowing away the competition so I think
uh I think we should leave well enough
alone and probably also leave on with
like the locker rooms and the bathrooms
let the organizations you know let the
uh owners of the buildings uh work work
that out I don't think there's like a
large I don't think there's a very large
problem about a lot of is are the fear
of what might happen more than anything
that has happened and certainly and
certainly it's illegal even for a man to
go into the men's room and assault
another man and it would be legal for
woman even assist you know woman with
excess chromosomes who's you know
clearly looks female everyone it's
illegal for her to like assault another
female and the in in the locker room or
even for her to go into the men's locker
room and assault a person I think we
have like sufficient laws on the books
that deal with that sort of case so so I
think this bill is a I think the
amendment like the underlying bill is is
unnecessary
so uh represent gson did you have oh
representative
Perez parents didn't call me because
they were offended parents called me
because they were
concerned concerned about the safety of
their children concerned about a sixth
grade girl having a UTI a seventh grade
boy urinating in on the bus because he
couldn't hold it any longer um there
it's
concern um not offended by it at all um
I don't understand I you know when when
talking to people about this and many
some that disagreed with me about it and
one of the things that said to them and
I'd like each of us to consider this if
you have children or young adult
children or
grandchildren consider the fact that
your child has been the number one track
star for the girls cross country and is
going to college on a scholarship based
on that but their senior year of high
school they lose every single event
because a um a male identifying as a
female is now allowed on the team but
that doesn't bother me as much as the
fact that for safety it is an issue it
doesn't bother me as much for the
bathroom bothers me
because they're afraid to go into it and
it's there's another place they could go
and you know young children or high
school kids don't understand why all of
a
sudden they have to compete when they
haven't have to compete with someone who
is born a different sex than they are
identifying at this has nothing to do
with how you identify it's not
discriminating against you because how
you
identify it's not discriminating against
you at all it's protecting the safe and
the Dignity of the of the majority and
the Privacy the privacy of the majority
I do not I'm an adult if I go into a
bathroom and a and
a someone with a gender IDE I can cope
with that that's all right I'm an adult
I can choose but we're not allowing
younger people that courtesy of being
safe comfortable
respected in private areas and we're not
allowing young people to succeed in
sports that they were succeeding in and
to lose where are the women standing up
for women's
rights thank you other comment did
somebody else uh yes representative
testerman I do think agree with
representative Perez to some extent and
I do think though that there is an issue
of identity when you identify as a black
person and you're
not you're going to have a little
difficulty getting whatever access you
want you identify as a female and you're
not and all of a sudden we get everybody
trying to defend you and I think that's
just
wrong I just don't think we have a right
to to make our personal Identity or as
as a function of what access we get I I
just can't accept
this I'm sorry representative L did I do
you have
sure so I feel first of all thank you
for taking U my comment um I just want
to say that times have changed and I
think these days we need to be open to
understanding what's going on in our
society um it's not it's not like um
what like you say that you go go along
and everybody is either um you know just
monogamous and they're just with with
within their own sex or not the problem
is is that we need to be willing to be
understanding um what's going on out
there and
um um I can even say in my own town
we've had some issues of of things and
I'm just going to say that the biggest
Pro the biggest thing is I find that a
lot of people out there are not willing
to open their minds to a lot of things
that have changed in our society and
people have to get more uh better
educated to know what exactly is going
on I deal as a nurse I deal with people
all the time I'm a labor nurse so I see
it number one
um people don't have to um on the uh
birth certificate now to say if a if
it's a boy or a girl that is not what's
happening it's they can choose not to
and have the child um uh decide on their
own what they want to be and but the
thing is people have to be educated and
I think um yes you know like I said um
there's a lot
of should say controversy in regards to
you know the sports teams there's you
know um but at the same
time you know a lot of people say Well
when a child is better educated about
this um or more educated about um
becoming transvesti or whatever uh
transsexual the problem
is no children are a lot more
understanding of what's going on there
than I think adults are and I think the
big thing is is we have to um Listen and
talk to people and be um and understand
and talk to our own children sit down
how did your day go what happened and
not so much just kind of um brushing off
of of and just sitting down with them
more um no is it a uh is it going to be
uncomfortable um uh conversations yes
but I think it's you know we really need
to I think think about when we go to
make a decision here that that it's not
was going I say a black and white
decision we really have to think about
exactly um the you know exactly talking
about the biological sex and no and
nobody can choose that nobody truly can
choose the life that your child will
leave live I mean pardon me will live or
or anybody's child would live you know
that's the thing is we're all
individuals and we have to realize that
and um I appreciate you just taking my
comment representative Stapleton did you
have something you want to say Yes
um personal
identity should be and is a personal ch
choice but the there has to be a
differenti entiation between personal
choice and statutory
purpose if we're going to have order
safety um respect um we we need to
differentiate between the personal
aspect
subjective and the statutory aspect
objective and I think we're Crossing
these things over and that's going to
give rise to
difficulty I'd like to follow up with
the idea of or title N9 I'm not sure
when that was formulated or written into
law but I would suspect that it was
during a
period when um in the context of
cultural understanding at the time so if
we have an absent uh absence of
separation within Title 9
law I believe it was probably because
the understanding cultural understanding
at the time was that separate in many
cases was orderly and required
and and
reasonable
so I I've got to go
with um supporting the amendment and the
bill um because of those differences
between personal identity and statutory
use thank you if I could just follow up
for a minute representative Testament I
I frequently find your comments very
thoughtful and your your division
between subjective and objective makes a
lot of sense to me and I think it's
something we ought to be reminded when
we try to make a whole series of
decisions the reason Title 9 was created
was not to um put in place
separate it was to say that public funds
other funds were all going for athletics
for men and women should also have
opportunities for example in um well in
every University in the country um you
know there's the football team the
basketball team the hockey team whatever
and with a lot of money a lot of
resources uniforms support the question
was should there not be comparable
opportunities for fine women athletes to
be able to participate and so that was
the reasoning behind it wasn't to to
make it separate but equal it was to
create an opportunity but I do want to
reiterate that I think you're very
thought-provoking when you talk about
objective and subjective I come down in
a different place than you do but in no
way does that challenge
your your perspective which I
respect thank you for that uh further
explanation I appreciate
it yeah I just want to go back to I
guess where originally started on this
this whole bill um it's a bill that
speaks about biological sex it's a bill
that does not speak at all about how
biological sex is defined um we heard
during the testimony multiple ways in
which biological sex could be defined
either external sexual traits it could
be chromosomes it could be hormonal and
I think there's others and every one of
those has an in an exception an unclear
or ambiguous State um I think it's very
dangerous to say that the government and
I know it's not mandated that it that it
must but it can apply a completely
undefined
characteristic um uh that most people
might feel they know what that what it
is but I don't think we ever got to a
conclusion nobody that I asked in
testimony ever came to a conclusion so I
think from that perspective alone and I
won't go into some of the other aspects
of the bill but you know I think that
makes it just
unworkable the only comment that I would
make uh and I think we probably oh I'm
sorry does somebody else have a comment
I didn't mean to oh
representative thank you for taking my
comment I have been listening very
closely to everybody I think we could
sit here all 20 of us and talk about it
all day I believe that those that are
for this bill are not going to change
their mind I believe those that are
against the bill are not going to change
their mind and I think it's time to vote
what I would like to see is something go
to the house floor for 400 people to
debate and vote that's that's just my
opinion now when we talk about equid
equility and
fairness being a biological female I
will say this and not I'm I'm not biased
I'm not against transgender or anybody
or anything but when we talk to
fist when it comes to females why is it
fair for a biological
male to be in a
sport with a biological females or other
females and there's no chance that those
females are going to beat that person in
that
sport I have been competitive all my
life I may not look at but I have I love
running in everything else if I ever
thought when I was younger I was
going to be in
track and work extensively year in and
year out in a biological male came along
and got in the sport and took it away
from me I think it's sad and I know and
I know what I'm talking about I grew
up with my father and four brothers I
know what strength is and even though I
grew up as a tom boy and was thought I
was very strong there is no way I was
ever stronger than the males in my
family or anybody else my husband and
nobody and it's just fness and somehow
we got to come to some conclusion and I
know people will say well what about the
transgender what are they supposed to do
there are other sports and I've been
looking in or other avenues of sports
and I've been looking into it but
different
categories that people can get into and
it's
fair and they're in a good spot okay
let's take someone somebody that's in
special education
and can't be in a regular sport they
have special
sports for special education people and
there's different kinds of sports for
you know I haven't looked into it that
much but I've just found something and I
want to read it extensively what I'm
trying to say is I'm not against anybody
but
somehow this female thing of unfairness
in sports has got to be settled
otherwise if I being a biological
female and I was in school if I was all
the girls I would quit my Sport and i'
tell the school I'm not playing anymore
thank
you just one comment when we when we're
looking at Sports and females playing
sports with males or vice versa and this
does happen in mixed martial arts they
they they train together together and
there's not a problem with it there's
not a problem you will train with men
that are larger than you and and you're
you're in position say in Brazilian
jiu-jitsu or wrestling and there's no
problem with this and why there's a
problem now I I just don't even
understand why people are bringing this
up and women too can compete at the same
level and by putting a bill like this
into effect as as kids progress you got
all different ages of kids playing
together in sports then it becomes a
problem from what I gather is when kids
become more sexually
active in in in schools and there their
lines of problem and if you're competing
for
scholarships of any
kind getting into sports I don't see
how I get frustrated with this I can't
I just know people can play together men
and women in sports equally they have
sports now racing marathons you're
basing it all just on strength and a
woman's vulnerability and being a victim
you're you're you're perpetuating the
victim and females and for me to base a
a a bill on that criteria alone doesn't
make sense at
all
I just want to remind everybody this is
not a shall bill this is a May uh May
bill which is entirely different they're
not being mandated to do this they're
given the opportunity and just I
understand that there are a lot of
sports that men and women can
C paddle ball lots of things that they
can do pool that type of thing but there
are sports that separate two men and
female at a certain age for example for
example my granddaughter played boys
with boys hockey up until she was 13 at
13 they separate them because they're
allowed to check and because of strength
it has nothing to do with speed it has
to do with the males are stronger she
compete she was in a she had a male 100
PB heavy than her same age she broke her
clavicle they are separated at ages for
safety this is a safety thing there's no
safety if you're both playing pool or
you're doing that type of thing it is a
safety issue and to discriminate against
women who are succeeding in a sport by
having a man come in and take that away
from them is discriminating against
women
I'm sorry we ready for a vote on
Amendment uh 20230
441 to uh uh House Bill 396 and I'd ask
the clerk to please call the role Vice
chairman Wallace yes rep Alexander yes
rep Andrews yes rep testerman yes rep
Stapleton yes rep trip yes rep gon yes
clerk votes yes rep Perez yes rep Smith
no rep Horgan no rep D Lorenzo no rep
Kenny no rep Paige no rep MC Beth no rep
Divine no rep Lonzo no rep Eaton no rep
turer no chairman Lynn
yes motion fails 10 to 10
all right
um is there another
motion Mr chair I move on to
pass I'll I'll second that
motion this is on the main Bill all
right right any
discussion all right are we ready
for this ought to pass on the main bill
and I
think uh uh candidly this is to for the
purpose of getting the bill to the floor
where the the amendment can then be
presented again um all right uh any any
discussion any further discussion on the
main Bill all right so I guess we're
ready for a vote then ask the share to
call I the clerk to call the role please
Vice chairman Wallace yes rep Alexander
yes rep Andrews yes re testerman yes re
Stapleton yes re trip yes re G yes clerk
votes yes rep Perez yes rep Smith no rep
Horgan no rep D Lorenzo no rep Kenny no
rep paage no rep McBeth no rep Divine no
rep lza no rep Eaton no rep turer no
chairman Lynn yes motion bails 10 to
10 all right um so
now is there another is there another
motion
um is any go to the floor this way with
no motion with no majority vote 10 to 10
and when it gets to the floor the first
um uh motion will be ought to pass right
I'm just wonder we don't so you don't
need to have an it an itl motion voted
on now we can just that can somebody
body else can just make that motion on
the floor well if I mean if if it didn't
no if this I mean if I assume that
someone and I don't know who it will be
will um write the
report